you ever hang out with deshawn watson in
h-town
i ain't never met bro yeah you'd have to
be hanging out at a massage parlor to
meet him man
y'all don't know what that [ __ ] so you
gotta stop this this is my thing i think
what actually happened
was
he's probably just a normal dude who was
like paying masseuses
whether or not those masseuses were
actual masseuses or women
who you know how you go to get massages
should i'm not saying me but
[ __ ] begin massages they'd be
getting [ __ ] the happy ending at the
end i think that that lawyer they had
like a lawyer who found like one of
these chicks and then like put the word
out to everybody and then like now
there's just women coming out the
[ __ ] woodworks and it's a bad thing
it used to be some [ __ ] like that
and like you said bro like you said back
to your situation like not saying that
they're the same but like we don't even
know all the facts like he's literally
got nine figures on the line
for him it makes sense just to get it to
go away even if it's [ __ ] and he's
claiming his innocence that's a bigger
hustle in that lane versus mine for sure
for sure because you're dealing with
someone who's like a lot of people that
come when i was even going through that
[ __ ] what's athletes mm-hmm couple
of notes because rappers freestyle you
know they'll they'll go through [ __ ] but
a lot of athletes and they say the same
thing they they for sure didn't do it
but they were like man just to get that
[ __ ] on but i paid i said bro i'm not
doing it cause even more so than in
hip-hop if you're an athlete your public
image is so much more of whether or not
a team will even sign you for sure right
it's like it don't matter if it's that's
what's crazy about like you said the
athlete [ __ ] i feel really bad for those
guys if they really didn't do anything
wrong it's a lot of them that that's a
lot of them that's a hustle bro that's a
broke [ __ ] hustle broke [ __ ] hustle
for sure broke [ __ ] hustle that's why
when they try to
and like i say right now i can be one of
them people who kind of like blind side
about [ __ ] because my situation a
[ __ ] not seeing him in
particular but i'm going to give him up
for the
the the the benefit of the doubt just
because i know i've been through that
same situation and i know how people can
try to curl and keep on coming with
[ __ ] i'm talking about just and
they'll just keep on posting the
[ __ ] it'll make you look like you
just a [ __ ] animal bro so i know what
bro going through when it comes to that
[ __ ] and he probably literally didn't do
nothing i'm not saying he did not we
don't know
but but but based on his side he didn't
do nothing right so and
and i know
in my situation i do a [ __ ]
thing and they and they trying to dig
for it and they gonna make paint you to
be something that you ain't for sure